et notre invité politique ce matin et
adrien taquet bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'enfance et des familles on
a beaucoup de sujets à évoquer avec vous
on est ensemble pendant plus de 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représentée par denis carot de
nice-matin bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous ce matin on commence
évidemment par la crise sanitaire
adrien taquet olivier verrons qui était
devant les sénateurs hier matin il leur
a dit qu en fonction des livraisons de
doses il n'était pas sûr de pouvoir
vacciner d'ici l'été les 15 millions de
français fragile et le soir au 20h et
bien il nous dit que l'objectif c'est de
vacciner 40 3 millions de français au
mois de juin et la totalité des français
fin août est ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer cette contradiction quel est
le verrons qui dit la vérité
écoutez je pense que je même convaincu
pour le hêtre quotidien avec lui qu
olivier ferrand comme le reste du
gouvernement je le redit avec force
comme j'ai pu le dire mercredi devant
les devant les sénateurs fait montre de
transparence vis-à-vis des français
si les vertus depuis le début de la
crise ce qu'a dit olivier et veyran
effectivement c'est que si si l'ensemble
des doses que nous avons commandé dans
le cadre de l'union européenne des
différents laboratoires nous sont
effectivement livrés parce que pour
certains d'entre elles auront reçu
l'autorisation ce qui n'est pas le cas
encore de tous les deux tout les de tous
les vaccins ne lançons des laboratoires
et vu la montée en charge progressive de
la vaccination puisqu'il faut se réjouir
après les quelques difficultés du début
peut-être des premiers jours oui il ya
eu quelques personnes qui effectivement
ont étendu au téléphone il ya eu
quelques rendez-vous qui ont été
déprogrammés mais aujourd'hui sont plus
de cent mille de nos concitoyens qui
sont vaccinées chaque jour on dépend
toujours des doses dont nous disposons
savons aujourd'hui été livrés je crois
d'un point 9 millions de doses nous
vaccinons cent mille personnes nous
avions annoncé que d'ici la fin janvier
le pré mistral est dit qu'on espérait
avoir vacciné 1 millions de nos
concitoyens
ça sera franchi ce week end je crois
donc on voit bien qu'on est en phase
ascendante donc si on poursuit sur ce
rythme là est une fois encore si
l'ensemble des 2 me sont livrés une fois
encore des plantes de ce stock enfin
voilà c'est ça je pense qu'on l'a dit
depuis le départ c'est une donnée et et
bien nous pouvons espérer effectivement
avoir d'ici l'été avoir vacciné grande
majorité voire quasi totalité nos
concitoyens mais mais voilà revenu des
connaissances ou que vous avez sur le ça
dépend évidemment des livraisons du
sceau des livraisons ça dépend de la
veille de la validation aussi de
certains vaccins compte tenu de l'état
de vos connaissances aujourd'hui est ce
qu on est plutôt sur les déclarations du
matin à savoir
on n'est pas sûr de pouvoir vacciner
tout le monde d'ici l'été moi je
l'écouté lits générant hier soir il a
fixé le cadre c'est celui que je viens
vous de vous exposer je crois de toute
façon que l'année que nous venons de
traverser nous a tous conduits je
l'espère à un peu de prudence et de
modestie aussi probablement
voilà donc écouter c'est la dynamique
dans laquelle on s'inscrit c'est ce
qu'on essaie de faire savez il y avait
beaucoup de polémiques souvenez-vous sur
les tests aujourd'hui on a parlé plus du
tout hein on teste des millions de nos
concitoyens chaque mois je pense qu'on
est un des pays qui doit tester le plus
en europe
bon voilà donc les choses sont très
bonne dynamique
en revanche il ya des polémiques sur les
doses de vaccination vous les entendez
notamment de la part des élus locaux qui
disent on est prêt mais on n'a pas les
doses alors vous avez provoqué un peu un
tollé mercredi au sénat lors des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
vous avez invité les maires à ne pas
ouvrir plus de centres de vaccination
que ce que l'état leur a demandé vous
les avez invité à ne pas prendre plus de
créneaux de réservations que ce que le
nombre de doses leur permettent de faire
est ce que vous regrettez ce que vous
avez dit au sénat et est ce que c'est
vraiment le moment de pointer du doigt
les maires alors ce que j'ai vu ce que
j'ai commencé par dire et c'est la
condition du gouvernement et du premier
ministre évidemment c'est que la
réussite de la campagne vaccinale
elle repose sur la bonne coopération la
bonne articulation entre les services de
l'état et les pouvoirs publics locaux et
quand j'ai des pouvoirs publics locaux
ce ne sont pas que les élus locaux
c'est aussi l'état déconcentré c'est
aussi les rse si les préfets qui ont un
rôle important à jouer dans cette
ce déploiement est cette déclinaison
territoriale de la bêtise vaccinale mais
c'est vrai qu'au début les premiers
jours effectivement je voulais dit on
dépend beaucoup des stocks de vaccins
dont nous disposons collectivement on
avait dit effectivement un certain
nombre de responsables locaux qui
avaient c'est pas 500 mille doses de
disponible et donc ça ne servait à rien
de d'ouvrir 3000 ou 5000 rendez-vous
créneau horaire et c'est là qu'il ya pu
avoir un peu de frictions et un peu
effectivement de décisions des français
je pense très sincèrement oui c'est un
peu et un peu de polémique mercredi moi
je veux pas être dans la polémique
vraiment pas je pense que tout ça se
régule depuis alors mes jeux wii je me
suis permis jeu
je me suis bien mis l'a fait je me suis
dit je suis un peu de démagogie de la
part des maires qui en font trop il ya
eu un peu de jeu politique mais comme on
avait pu vous comme on avait pu le voir
à d'autres moments sur les masques moi
j'ai vu un dans mon même dans mon dans
mon département dans ma région
quelques élus locaux qui avaient pu
essayer de voile à 2 2 comment dire oui
peut-être de profiter de ce moment là
pour pour faire un peu de politique
bon tout ça je pense très sincèrement je
vous le dis vraiment ça on n'est pas
grave si les fossiles et les difficultés
des deux a mené une campagne de
vaccination comme ça au niveau national
avec des avec des nouveaux vaccins des
procédures dont vous savez
d'acheminement de conservation des
vaccins qui sont très compliqué pour
tout le monde c'est normal qu'ils aient
un peu de friction je pense que sanaa ça
ne mérite pas qu'il y ait des polémiques
ni d'un côté ni de l'autre je prends ma
part voilà je pense que ça se régule que
dans quelque temps on n'en parlera plus
comme aujourd'hui on ne parle plus des
tests
voilà vous parlez de jeu politique mais
on voit que certaines collectivités sont
très très engagé très très impliquée sur
la mise en place dudit statut ce livre
dedans de vaccination et gère la
logistique un patient est ce que c'est
pas allé un peu loin que de dire que
certains jouent un jeu politique constat
que je me suis permise permis de faire
mais dans la très grande majorité des
cas je vous rejoins absolument c'est
effectivement l'engagement des élus
locaux mais aussi enfin excusez moi
aussi des services de l'état déconcentré
j'aimerais qu'on leur tape souvent
dessus moi j'aimerais aussi leur rendre
hommage aux agendas préfet dans les
préfectures dans les ars qui depuis un
plus d'un an maintenant dormait peu pour
essayer de faire en sorte que nous
traversions cette crise sanitaire il
faut aussi savoir leur rendre hommage
parce que j'entends beaucoup d'élus ce
soit l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat
leur taper dessus et je pense qu'il faut
aussi leur rendre hommage et de la très
grande majorité des cas évidemment un
quasi totalité les élus locaux sont très
investis très engagé et je le redis et
une fois encore des interventions
commencer je crois vous vérifierez sur
les bandes à chaque fois par sa part
rendre hommage et part et par pointé la
nécessité de cette bonne articulation
cette bonne coopération main dans la
main avec les élus locaux passent pour
toutes les raisons que vous exposez
olivier baron n'a pas annoncé hier soir
de nouvelles mesures et le porte parle
du
gouvernement a expliqué qu'il n'y en
aurait pas avant la semaine prochaine
olivier v rendit à tant vouloir attendre
les faits du couvre feu
quand on décortique les chiffres et
c'est ce qu'on a fait à nice matin dans
un article a été publié ce matin on voit
que le taux d'incidence baisse un petit
peu depuis la mise en place du couvre
feu le à 18 heures le 2 janvier
mais metz finalement très peu est ce que
ça ne démontre pas l'inefficacité ou en
tout cas le fait que le couvre-feu ce
n'est pas suffisant écoutez infections
sur une quinzaine de départements qui
avaient mis en place le couvre feu de
façon un peu anticipée par rapport au
reste du pays on voit un effet sur sur
l'incidence est ce que ça sera suffisant
notamment par rapport à la circulation
du fameux variant angles m dont on vous
voit et on s'est un peu quasi
mécaniquement c'est une course contre la
monte 5 % des cas dans les alpes aux
noix et je crois qu'au niveau national
ça doit être autour de 2,5 mais ça
évolue très vite par définition
malheureusement est ce que ça sera
suffisant pour contenir je ne sais pas
ce que l'on fait à chaque fois en
français commence à en avoir l'habitude
on sait qu'il ya toujours des délais de
deux semaines deux semaines trois
semaines plus tôt de maintenant pour
voir l'impact des décisions que l'on
prend sur notamment le système
hospitalier
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a dit
qu'on allait attendre effectivement le
milieu de semaine prochaine pour prendre
des mesures j'imagine que dans un
conseil de défense mardi ou mercredi
c'est généralement dans ces eaux là que
ça se passe c'est que des mesures seront
prises
aujourd'hui je peux pas vous dire c'est
la grande question c'est est ce qu'on
veut un confinement ou pas est-ce que le
gouvernement est en train de préparer
les esprits à sa très sincèrement je
n'en sais rien effectivement les
tendances ne sont pas ne sont pas
extrêmement positive on voit que
les entrées en hospitalisation ont
plutôt tendance à augmenter en
réanimation de la même façon voilà donc
la tension sur le système hospitalier
commença à augmenter on sait que ce
variant anglais se diffuse très
rapidement voilà une façon un peu
exponentielle c'est ce qu'on a constaté
dans les pays européens
donc on essaie de contenir ce qu'on a
fait il ya la course contre la montre
avec le virus aussi voilà on est on est
c'est une course contre la montre
plus que jamais avec l'enjeu et le
risque des vacances scolaires qui arrive
à partir du 5 février il avait été
envisagé à un moment d'allonger les
vacances scolaires est ce que c'est un
scénario qui peut être à nouveau mis sur
la table
écoutez une fois encore moi je veux pas
vous faire de ne fausse annonce ou
risquer de cesser effectivement je peux
pas dire mieux que ce que vous venez
d'évoquer sa avait été envisagé je ne
sais pas si ça sera quelque chose de
retenue voilà je pense qu'il faut
vraiment attendre la semaine prochaine
pour voir ce qui ce qui sera décidé
est-ce que ce contexte sanitaire a des
conséquences sur la petite enfance dont
vous avez la charge de l'alu marlène
schiappa dans le parisien de dire que
les signalements pour les violences
faites aux femmes avaient augmenté de
60% durant le second confinement est ce
que vous avez constaté une augmentation
des violences sur les enfants et de
combien
alors il ya deux types de conséquences
yonhap real en plus il ya évidemment des
conséquences en niveaux de la scolarité
on sait que le confinement les
difficultés actuelles de
de scolarité potentiellement accroît les
difficultés antérieures
il ya des conséquences sur les violences
effectivement notamment pendant le
premier confinement il ya un double
effet c'est la question la famille dans
certains cas est un lieu de danger pour
certains enfants et donc on avait
notamment au cours du premier
confinement renvoyer les enfants chez
eux et paris on a fermé des écoles donc
on avait perdu nos yeux parce qu'en
réalité de l'école est l'endroit où qui
fournit le plus d'informations
préoccupantes dont il y avait un double
effet comme ça on s'était mobilisé les
français s'était mobilisé 1 était
beaucoup plus vigilants les certaines
semaines les appels aux 119 avaient
augmenté de 4 le numéro de l'enfance en
danger un lot 119 avait augmenté de 80%
sa traduisait à l'époque probablement
une augmentation des violences
et ça s'est révélé être le cas 1
quelques mois après les remontées des
chu notamment des urgences pédiatriques
nous montre que en gros si vous voulez
sur le premier confinement ça vaut pour
surtout les hôpitaux parisiens
vous avez eu 30 % de baisse des
hospitalisations pédiatrique
parce qu'il ya eu moins de bobo dans la
cour parce qu'il avait plus la cour etc
mais parmi les hospitalisations pour
enfants il ya une hausse de 50% pour
faits de violence donc il ya eu un
phénomène d'augmentation
puis un deuxième effet qui est qui me
préoccupe tout autant enfin y'a pas dire
archi évidemment mais c'est la question
des conséquences psychologiques de la
crise sur les enfants les conséquences
psy à la fois sur les tout-petits vous
avez des enfants qui sont nés il ya un
an
eh bien les professionnels qu'ils ont vu
de la petite enfance ils les ont vus
masqué depuis un an quasiment ses
raisons pour laquelle moi j'ai je
remercie la caisse nationale et avec une
vocation familiale la cnaf
j'ai demandé à son conseil
d'administration à quelques mois de
voter un budget exceptionnel pour
fournir l'ensemble des procès à la
petite enfance de masques transparent
parce qu'on sait à quel point pour un
tout jeune enfant c'est important de
voir les sourires les visages les
expressions du visage et c'est important
pour son développement
donc il ya ça est très attentif sur les
plus âgés mais pas très très âgées
encore à partir de 6 ans qui porte le
masque à l'école désormais donc on
regarde et on développe un certain
nombre d'outils notamment pour permettre
aux professionnels l'éducationnationale
d'un côté aux parents de l'autre pour
pouvoir déceler un mal-être chez leurs
enfants
et puis troisième population encore plus
dont la santé mentale se dégradent est
déjà depuis plusieurs années sur les
adolescents est donc là on est très très
sensible moi je regarde les signaux
faibles
j'ai fait une réunion avec un ensemble
de pédopsychiatres la président de la
société française de pédiatrie en
novembre on a réitéré sa avec le
président de la république qui lui aussi
très inquiets sur ce sujet là c'était de
dire ça dix jours le président la
république a fait un certain nombre
d'annoncés à la suite de ça on d'une
part en convoquant des assises de la
santé mentale notamment sur les enfants
avant avant l'été en nous demandant de
travailler au renforcement de la
médecine scolaire d'un côté et à voir
comment on peut faire en sorte de
rembourser peut-être des consultations
de psy pour pour les enfants bref il ya
une grosse préoccupation sur la question
est fondamentale et une fois qu'on sera
sorti la crise sanitaire
ça ne va pas s'arrêter parce qu'on peut
anticiper que la dégradation de la
situation économique va se poursuivre et
s'amplifier que vous avez donc à la voir
des cellules familiales des gens qui
vont perdre leur boulot avec des
tensions et donc des risques sur sur les
enfants voilà il faut être vigilant
l'autre sujet important adrien taquet
c'est la question de l'inceste le livre
de camiers kouchner a libéré la parole
vous avez vu ce déferlement de
témoignages sur les réseaux sociaux
sous le hashtag mito inceste est-ce que
vous avez été surpris par l'ampleur de
ces témoignages et surtout comment le
gouvernement va y répondre
alors j'ai déjà impressionné par le
courage des victimes et je pas surpris
non parce que moi la question des
violences faites aux enfants et en
particulier des violences sexuelles dont
l'inceste n'est pas que mes dents
l'inceste moi c'est un des combats ford
de moments de mon de ma mandature comme
on dit c'est un sujet que j'ai pris tout
de suite dont je parle beaucoup ce que
je pense qu'il faut parler il faut
briser le mur du silence
il faut en faire un cheikh la situation
des enfants dans ce pays face à la
violence et à la violence sexuelle est
elle
c'est à dire est tellement
catastrophique que c'est pas le
gouvernement tout seul et le ministre
avec ses petits bras qui va la résoudre
c'est quand ça sera devenue un sujet de
société et c'est ce qui est en train de
se faire et je peux vous dire que depuis
deux ans moi pour venir parler sur les
plateaux de télé de ces sujets là je me
galère est un peu donc c'est très bien
enfin qu'on en parle et vous avez
évidemment votre la jouer les victimes
londres elles sont en train de le faire
il faut qu'on accompagne cette parole ce
qu'on apporte des solutions je vous
vous en parler et il faut que ça reste à
la une de l'actualité
demain il va peut-être se passer un truc
et puis on passera à autre chose là
c'est plus possible et si on l'écouté
vous c'est ce que je disais hier au
moment de la delà des débats sur la
proposition de loi biyong soir charles
est au banc avec avec eric dupond
moretti s'est depuis aussi loin qu'on
puisse en souvenir et probablement
avancé depuis le milieu des années
quatre heures eva thomas qui a la télé
parle de l'inceste puis denise
bombardier puis vous avez sarah abitbol
et puis andrea bescond bref ya des coups
de boutoir comme ça on en parle on parle
des chiffres tout le monde tombe de sa
chaise et puis on les oublie le
lendemain bon là les coups de boutoir
sont de plus en plus fort de plus en
plus rapprochées et donc on peut espérer
qu'enfin enfin on va pouvoir
collectivement faire face à ce sujet
parce que ça va secouer ans
parce qu'en réalité quand on regarde les
chiffres vous les connaissez un français
sur 10 qui aurait été victime d'inceste
on ne parle que de l'inceste
il ya tous les autres types de violences
sexuelles qui n'ont pas lieu dans la
famille dans un cadre sportif dans une
institution
un français sur trois qui dit connaître
quelqu'un victime un set
c'est à dire que là chacun d'entre nous
sommes soient victimes ou avons dans
notre entourage très proche un agresseur
mais quelle réponse alors adrien taquet
alors les réponses elles sont de
plusieurs ordres
elles sont déjà en train d'être déployés
pour certaines et il faut aller plus
loin nous on a travaillé dès le début
dès mon arrivée mon janvier 2019
oui c'est ça on a travaillé sur un plan
de lutte contre les violences avec les
associations avec les ministères ce que
c'est trés interministériel évidemment
et donc j'ai présenté un plan de lutte
contre les violences faites aux enfants
le 20 novembre 2019 qui était le 30e
anniversaire de la convention
internationale droits de l'homme il ya
22 mesures là dedans il y en a certaines
qui porte sur les violences sexuelles à
la fois prévention formation et là on
peut aller plus loin très clairement on
forme mieux les magistrats on peut mieux
former les professionnels de santé
je pense qu'on peut mieux accompagner
encore les professionnels de l'éducation
nationale on en parlait tout à l'heure
même si ce sont aujourd'hui les premiers
pour rien je pense qu'il faut qu'on
sensibilise davantage les enfants eux
mêmes et ça on y travaille avec
jean michel blanquer on va on va
accélérer la dessus il faut il ya tout
un travail sur le recueil de la parole
des victimes c'est quand vous êtes un
enfant de 4 ans qui a été victime de
viol par son père bahar cuir sa parole
c'est pas simple ça serait pas dans un
commissariat avec des gens pas formés
donc on a développé en déploie sur
l'appel des unités d'accueil pédiatrique
c'est à l'hôpital des professionnels
formés un regard pluridisciplinaire
c'est filmé et on a il y en aura un
parterre et un par département d'ici
2000 2022
bon on lutte contre les pédocriminels on
l'a durci les peines pour les personnes
qui consultent des sites
pédopornographiques
ces gens là seront de fait désormais
automatiquement inscrit au fichier des
agresseurs sexuels
on a on a élargi tous qui contrôle des
antécédents judiciaires des gens qui
travaillent avec là avec des enfants
les stars et c'est donc là des choses
mais il faut aller plus loin
faut accompagner cette parole et il faut
faire c'est me to inceste est évidemment
formidable
je crois qu'on est à près de 100000
témoignages enfin voilà donc là il ya
une vague elle et elle est formidable
tout le monde ne va pas sur twitter tout
le monde n'a pas la parole à une
population qui est plus touchée que les
autres c'est des enfants en situation de
handicap
les gens qui parlent pas les gens qui
sont déficients mentaux ont des
problèmes psychiques
ça aussi c'est un sujet bon voila et
donc il ya il ya tout ça tout ça à faire
alors il ya une question centrale sur ce
sujet ce qui est celle de
l'imprescriptibilité
[Musique]
la plate forme de démocratie
participative melkor dévoile aujourd'hui
les résultats d'une consultation
citoyenne sur les violences faites aux
enfants et plus de 80% des participants
sont favorables à ce principe de
l'imprescriptibilité est-ce que comment
on peut avancer sur ce sujet alors il ya
la fiction de sujet qui cristallise un
peu les débats et ils sont importants et
le gouvernement et je pense que nous en
avons nous avons nous en avons fait
montre hier à l'occasion de la ppl
billon et c'est une première étape veut
avancer et va avancer sur le sujet ces
deux sujets c'est le concerne la
question de l'âge du consentement et
devant tuellement un éventuel seuil
et puis à la question de la prescription
bilité ces îles sont centraux ils sont
importants mais une fois encore la
question des violences sexuelles un
cesse c'est évidemment bien plus large
que ses seules de questions n'a parlé de
prévention de lutte etc et
d'accompagnement psychologique mais
quand il m'a répondu oui elle est
importante mais c'est pas parce qu'on va
passer l'imprescriptibilité pour les
crimes à partir de maintenant pour les
30 prochaines années ou bouger ça je
consentement que ça va résoudre la
question des pros des violences
sexuelles dans notre pays enfin que les
choses soient très claires aussi là
dessus bien nommé serious man tout
résoudre mais ça fait partie de cette
manière de faire avancer c'est que j'ai
évidemment évidemment évidemment et même
en termes de signal social donné ça
c'est indéniable mais la prise en charge
psychologique aujourd'hui des victimes
qui est défaillante est aussi un sujet
est on est on va y travailler sur la
question de la prescription vite et
écouté hier a été adopté il ya eu des
débats très intéressants de très bons
très bons niveaux d'ailleurs parmi les
sénateurs et avec le garde des sceaux il
faut le il faut le reconnaître sur ceux
sur cette question là ça saoule et ma
saison de prem juridique de hiérarchie
aussi des nez parce que si vous mettez
là prescriptive ilité pour réfection des
crimes sexuels sur enfants pourquoi pas
sur les crimes tout simplement avec
torture sur enfants qui sont tout aussi
horrible enfin sans faire d archi entre
les uns et les autres
bon hier a été adoptée quelque chose
d'assez intéressant même si peut-être il
faudra la réécrire techniquement c'est
la question de la prescription glissante
c'est à dire si un nouveau
rim est constatée il suspend les
mécanismes de prescription qui était
acquise et à l'oeuvre c'était une
proposé un amendement socialiste sauf
erreur de marie pierre de la gontrie qui
a fait si on est plutôt opposés ce sans
vouloir parler pour elle à la question
de la pression du tc assez divisés un
même parmi les associations même parmi
les psychiatres
vous avez des psychiatres qui sont très
favorables muriel salmona par exemple
d'une grande psychiatre sur ces sujets
là vous en est d'autres hélène romano
par exemple qu'ils le sont qu'ils le
sont moins et effectivement marie pierre
de la gontrie n'est pas bon cet
amendement a obtenu l'avis favorable du
gouvernement du garde des sceaux
donc c'est une première avancée qui
répond elle reprendra
écoutez en tout cas j'en a émis un avis
favorable est reçue alors vous l'avez
protège pas s'ils voulaient l'interroger
mais on va nous continuons à travailler
aussi d'autres stations landais de la
navette parlementaire et et ses
propositions sur une loi qui a été votée
hier au sénat pour qu'il aille à
l'assemblée il faut qu'il soit repris
soit par les députés soit par le
gouvernement est ce que le gouvernement
va le reprendre ce texte et l'inscrire à
l'ordre du jour ne la leur mais le
gouvernement veut avancer sur ces sujets
là veut avancer sur la question du
soldat je vais avancer sur la question
l'imprescriptibilité tout cas d une
prescription veut avancer sur d'autres
sujets qui restent encore ouverts qui
n'ont pas trouvé forcément de réponse
hier qui sont des sujets compliqués la
question de l'inceste est aujourd'hui
circonstances aggravantes
est ce qu'on doit en faire un crime
spécifique oui ou non alors alors ce ne
sont pas des questions auxquelles on
répond par mail et vous des liens
jacques marcon elle même qui dit qu'il
je vais vendre je vais vous levez vous
je vais vous répondre ça ne se répondent
par ou pas par oui ou par non ça de
trois implications juridiques mais aussi
pour les victimes
en réalité parce que c'est à elle qu'il
faut penser avant tout c'est la raison
pour laquelle le président de la
république nous a demandé à eric dupond
moretti et à moi même de mener une
petite concertation rapide auprès de
l'ensemble des parties prenantes
notamment les associations les juristes
spécialisés etc pour que dans le cadre
de cette navette parlementaire le
gouvernement puisse aussi avancé
façonner son idée sur ces différents
sujets voilà il y aura quatre cinq
thèmes qui seront mis sur la table ce
qu'on vient d'évoquer concertation qui
débute quand qui va débuter la semaine
prochaine avec le garde des sceaux et
qui va nous permettre voilà
nous de nous de nous de nous faire notre
idée sur ces sujets là et pour au moment
de la navette pas du retour de la
navette parlementaire pouvoir voilà
avoir une position définitive du
gouvernement étant entendu tout changer
et je ne sais pas je ne sais pas
répondre à la question vous est posée je
ne sais pas quel sera le véhicule
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que nos
médias si vous a demandé une
concertation mais qui débute la semaine
prochaine
il vous a donné une échéance j'imagine
pour les de toute façon il faut que faut
que les choses avancent eux dans les
dans les semaines à venir un donc est ce
que ça se passe avait prise je ne sais
pas je ne sais pas si ça sera une
reprise
ce que je sais c'est que le gouvernement
veut avancer et je vais avancer vite
donc on va déjà se mettre d'accord sur
le fond après avoir parlé un peu avec
les actes des différents acteurs c'est à
peu près ce que pensent les uns les
autres mais on a ce besoin d'échangés
encore notamment en fonction de ce qui
c'est ce qui a été adopté hier et ce qui
s'est passé hier à se positionner là
dessus et après est ce que ça sera une
reprise billon par ouvre ou les députés
la puck en marche est ce que ça sera une
ppl spécifiques comme une députée
alexandra louis qui travaille depuis
quelque temps sur ce sujet l'un qui
avait été rapporteur de la loi de
mariage à garda est ce que ça sera un
projet de loi excuse on ira s'accrocher
sur une proposition de loi portée par
des députés franchement je ne sais pas
ce qu'ils font
la proposition de la bille on ne restera
pas uniquement à l'état du sénat que le
gouvernement va s'emparer d'une forme la
question que ce travail occasion du
consentement de la prescription de
qu'est ce qu'on est ce que l'inceste un
crime spécifique ou un bref toutes ces
questions là sont pas les questions
simples nous allons avancer sur le sujet
ça je vous le confirme
un dernier mot de nîmes pour terminer
sur l'aide sociale à l'enfance peut-être
vous avez présenté votre feuille de
route concernant la petite enfance vous
admettez vous même
que le calendrier est plutôt serré qu'il
reste un nom utile quel est votre
priorité
alors effectivement
écoutez moi j'essaye depuis un an de
gérer la crise notamment au plus près
des acteurs qu'ils soient de la petite
enfance qui soit de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance d'imaginer kan à fermer
l'école pour les foyers les max était
compliqué est-ce qu'on peut essayer les
réformes quand on essaye et ont poussé
je remercie ce qu'on sollicite beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup les acteurs différents
acteurs et j'essaye moi je pousse je
pousse le pouce et parce qu'il faut il
faut il faut aussi que la vie continue
il ya aussi des sujets importants on a
initié des choses on a fait bosser des
gens moi je veux que les choses aillent
à leur goût et donc il ya un espèce de
dictature d'urgence là que je ressens
chaque matin quand je me lève il ya pas
mal de sujets initiée sur la petite
enfance on a déjà fait des choses
réforme des modes d'accueil congé
paternité tout ça un peu dans le sait le
projet des 1000 premiers jours de
l'enfant et donc ça on va continuer à
déployer cette année et puis à la
réforme de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
on pourra en parler longtemps je pense
que c'est intéressant plus simple de vos
auditeurs des dans les départements vous
préparer une loi ça fait un an et demi
on prépare effectivement un texte et un
an et demi de concertation moi je bosse
beaucoup avec l'association des
départements de france avec les
départements avec les associations avec
les anciens enfants protégés notamment
pour renforcer la gouvernance c'est un
peu techno n'y aura pas que ça met
notamment la gouvernance le pilotage de
cette aide sociale à l'enfance qui est
une compétence partagée entre les
départements et l'état l'éducation la
santé c'est beaucoup chez nous que ça se
passe il faut qu'on s'organise tous aux
sourds autour de l'enfant pour éviter
les ruptures et pour améliorer la prise
en charge ça devrait arriver au premier
trimestre face à va arriver au premier
trimestre de ceux de cette année en
conseil des ministres là aussi c'est une
ppl si c'est une ppl si c'est par là et
elle se sera pesée on est en train de
voir ça ça sera prêt à lons une tpe
voilà donc examiné au parlement d'ici
quelques semaines d'ici d'ici la fin du
présent trimestre soit vous viendrez
nous en parle et adrien avec les très
grands passages de sa mère sylvie très
intéressant merci d'avoir ce matin merci
denis car on regarde la une de nice
matin ce sont les loups est là une de
nice-matin des loups à battre fond
d'interrogations merci denis cardonne
ouvert ce matin pas de souci tout le
bétail toi
[Musique]